I was just talking to somebody in our
community she's a real estate agent in
Hawaii and she is seeing so many views
coming in just from people just wanting
to look at houses in Hawaii and so she
has built her YouTube channel and gained
more subscribers and Views and again
bringing in that second income stream
just because people love to watch and so
she's gotten really good at opening up
new opportunities and supplementing her
income while also still bringing in New
Leads for her primary business real
estate is also one of the highest RPM CP
M topics and so to clarify what that is
for listeners that's just the amount of
money YouTube pays you for 1,000 views